when the Argentina Poland fixtures come
out
um I said to martinus straight away get
me that shirt he had the plug yeah I
like to be fair I didn't have a time I
didn't have a chance to speak to him
when we were at the World Cup obviously
because he had games and then after the
game he come up to me and said I've got
you a present so I was like all right
and I was suddenly thinking what is it
he just said come in the changer and
follow me so I followed him and he had a
bag and it had messy shirt in it yes
[Music]
when you line up at the tunnel in the
World Cup
um were you able to take it all in what
was like do you have to pin yourself is
it I'm in I'm in the world I'm at the
World Cup yeah people like I've had a
lot of a lot of questions like that
um and sort of when you're there you cut
like it's hard to take him because
you're like so focused on your job and
obviously you get when you before the
day after you play and obviously the
week you sort of get a bit of time to
yourself to relax but you're sort of in
the moment you know what I mean it's
sort of hard to take it in especially on
game day like playing in a World Cup
everyone's watching you just want to do
well so the adrenaline and all that and
all the obviously you obviously get a
little bit nervous as well
um just try and do do your best on the
pitch rather than taking everything in I
wish you could take it all in but yeah
it was hard to and when you get back and
you sort of speak about it you obviously
take it in and you've obviously played
in a major tournament so that's when you
take it in there I was at the Argentina
Poland game oh yeah yeah I was at that
yeah yeah it was brilliant tough day
but oh ultimately ended in Triumph yeah
yeah for you yeah the main the main aim
was to qualify yeah yeah definitely and
we've done that so did you think
were you aware because I was in the
stands and I think that in all of
football matches I've ever been to
across the world
Argentina's support oh I've never known
anything like it yeah incredible were
you aware of that on the pitch yeah yeah
I think before before the game kicked
off like the stadium was pretty much
full full of like Argentine fans
um yeah they were I think they were
probably the best fans in the tournament
I'd say yeah definitely they were
obviously when we played against them
they've got the players they have and it
made it even harder to play with the
fans so yeah no wonder they went on to
win it yeah
um and of course we've all seen on
social media you've got the shirt of
mbappe one of Messi as well firstly why
are they here and why they're not here
they're getting framed yeah frames okay
where they're going to be in your in
your house I'm not gonna say that just
in case
security reasons
yeah looking forward to getting them
framed and up yeah yeah how does it go
getting the player like that shot like
how do you at the end of the game do you
just go and have a conversation with
Messi and ask for the shirt or is it a
race because presumably you weren't the
only person on the pitch that wanted the
Lionel Messi shirt now well when the
messy uh when the Argentine and Poland
fixtures come out
um I said to martinus straight away get
me that shirt he had the plug yeah yeah
I didn't have
a chance to speak to him when we were at
the World Cup obviously because he had
games and then after the game he come up
to me and said I've got you a present
so I was like all right and I was
suddenly thinking what is it he just
said come in the changer and follow me
so I followed him and he had a bag and
it had messy shirt in it yeah
so that was good and then um the mbappe
one I just said to him towards the end
of the game like the 90th minute the
ball went out and I just said can I get
your shot after he said yeah bro no
worries yeah so then after that he went
off and celebrated or whatever and I
thought I'm just going to leave it and
then he'd come up to me in the tunnel
and took it off yeah oh man yeah yeah he
remembered you got in early then so you
got him before the full-time whistle
yeah but we like we were like walking I
was just walking off I weren't gonna
bother asking again I just thought
that's it and then he cut he like sent
me jogged over to me and just took it
off and I was like Sam yeah gentlemen
yeah I know yeah do you have a big
collection at home all yeah I got a
collection yeah I've got a few good ones
yeah I've got um
Memphis depay when we played Holland uh
Lewandowski got me a Bayern Munich one
uh JT Got Me A Sign Chelsea one the
captain under
and then them two to add on yeah class
so I might have to take it yeah yeah
yeah yeah actually collection that so
are you saying that Killian and Pepe's
got a sign Matty Casher hanging up in
his game yeah he probably used it to
clean the car or something
do you get a real shirt though yeah yeah
yeah yeah
it also you have nothing to wear yeah
yeah
um and then going on to
um playing Killian Buffet like what's
the game plan when you face it against
the caliber of yeah we watch videos
obviously a few days leading up to the
France game watch videos of him and he
was lightning I think the game we came
on against he didn't start a game and
because they qualified already I think
and he come on and he ripped it up and
we watched the end of that and he was
like Wow and then in the the day of the
game I just sat in my room and watched
clips of him
um the sort of how I'm gonna stop him
really and we had a good battle I think
we had a really good it was a good
challenge for me I think we had like 1v1
I think that was a few times he sort of
got around me and then a few where I
want to off him we had a few one-on-one
races as well
um
is that what it is with him is it the
pace like you know obviously he's
obviously he's a fantastic footballer
with a brilliant eye for goal and so
many attributes yeah but if it's one
thing from your perspective is it the
pace yeah is his pace is never like I
said before Sterling's rapid when I
played against Sterling he can run but
he is about pays another level yeah yeah
he just shoots off the go and you can't
actually do anything yeah
what did the gaffer say to you what was
his like plan to
[Applause]
I think he wanted me to back off him and
I didn't want to do that give him the
space yeah yeah he wanted me to back off
him
um but I thought if I get tight and
there's less chance of him sort of
running at me so the first like couple I
got tight and it was fine and then there
was a few where he gains gains a yard
and you can't do anything about it
um but I wanted to go tighter I sort of
yeah that was it mbappe or Messi who was
a harder challenge
well Messi was the other side of the
pitch so I'd say on Bape I think Messi's
quality is speaks for itself is way to
pass the way he controls the boys
obviously I don't need to sit here and
explain messy but I think for me and
bappa was the hardest test yeah would
you say that Lionel Messi is the goat
yeah I think so yeah I think
difficult in it because like them to him
and Ronaldo have done it at the top for
years and years 15 20 well however many
years they've done it so it's hard to
sort of single out one I think they're
both
um they're both goats yeah yeah and
who's the toughest player you faced at
the World Cup just generally was it one
of those two Yeah Yeah by far yeah yeah
definitely I'll tell you he's the
toughest yeah and international football
tournament football like that compared
to your everyday challenges at Aston
Villa is there a huge difference playing
in playing style do you find it very
different playing International
Tournament football compared to Premier
League yeah it's different obviously
because you've got different managers
different players so different styles
like of course there's different styles
um and I think International Football is
a little bit more
I wouldn't say slower but it's a little
bit more
um not tactical it's hard to say it's
still it's obviously top because every
every player that's playing is the best
in the country that's why they're
playing for the country so they're all
top players it's different yeah it's
different Premier League's like really
fast and like energetic and
so I mean quick players everywhere and
like you know what I mean so I'm not
saying there's not that in international
it's just a little bit different and he
talked about Emmy Martinez earlier um
what's he been like coming back from
obviously winning the World Cup is he
different now he's got you know man he's
been brilliant yeah he's been class yeah
um Emmy is a character life we saw in
the celebrations he's such a character
he's like that in training yeah yeah
he's insane yeah like if you miss and
you're if you're on his side you're
buzzing but if you're on the other side
and you lose and he saves he's laughing
at you he'll give you something yeah and
I only like joking yeah
he's amazing yeah he's such a good
goalie about it since he's been back
he's been brilliant so I know he's all
about nine games isn't he yeah yeah if
he's doing that in training yeah
and he doesn't even like when people say
it's taking it he's not doing it to be
personal like he does it in training to
us boys so I think it's just his way of
trying trying to win I think yeah and
it's amazing what he achieved there it's
really like the way that he the way that
he contributed to that yeah he he
changed the way that I spoke about
penalties without me even realizing you
know usually when a player steps up to
take a penalty I'll always go do you
think he'll score yeah yeah when Jimmy
Martin is in goal I'll go do you think
you'll save it yeah yeah and like I see
it every day like when we do penalties
quite a lot and he obviously don't save
everyone but he's like he's a big goal
isn't he yeah and in the World Cup he's
obviously proved it yeah and has he put
his medal in has he let you ever yeah he
brought his medal in yeah his first day
yeah yeah
come back and just obviously we
congratulated him and he showed us it
and that yeah because I don't know I
don't know if you struggling McAllister
obviously got that big yeah I've seen it
celebrations amazing no he had a yeah he
had a good welcome yeah yeah it wasn't
like what I seen at Brighton that was
brilliant to be fair
um but now all the lads and that wished
him like said well done and obviously
the coaching staff as well and yeah
we've obviously I think we had a game a
few days later when he come back so we
were just focused on that but yeah he's
been definitely one of the best
goalkeepers in the world at the moment
yeah yeah for sure I'd say he is
probably yeah I think he is and he's
just won the World Cup
basically not one I met but he's
obviously done major major impact on
them winning the World Cup I think he's
he's up there with the best in the world
yeah
[Music]
people go oh you're hard don't mind that
we didn't win enough games right facts
the eight games that remaining were
arguably the best run of games on paper
so that was the only way I couldn't get
I was like well that's the best run and
you're taking this out two days before
the best run well if you've got a lap
dancer you'd have to spin again so it's
your fine to get the number of so when
you do the laptop genius